Narrator: BRING ON THE CHEER.
IT'S A CHRISTMAS MIRACLE!
Narrator: IT'S A SPECIAL
HOLIDAY EPISODE OF "SHARK TANK."
NAILED IT.
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH THIS
IDEA? DID YOU HAVE A BAD DREAM?
Narrator: IN THE TANK,
ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
IF I HAVE TO TAKE OUT
ANOTHER MORTGAGE ON MY HOUSE,
I WILL.
WHOA.
I HAVE RECHRISTENED YOU
"THE BEAST."
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA,
THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
WHAT YOU'VE DONE
IS AMAZING.
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
YOU HAVE A HISTORY
OF TAKING REAL CRAP
AND TURNING IT INTO GOLD.
[ LAUGHS ]
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
I'M A CREATIVE MIND
ON CRACK.
I THINK YOU HAVE
A LONG WAY TO GO.
MAYBE YOU JUST SAVED YOURSELF
FROM DEATH.
YOU GOT TO LEAVE
WITH A SHARK.
LET ME EXPLAIN SOMETHING TO YOU,
MR. WONDERFUL.
GRR!
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT FROM
WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2 BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS WHAT THE ENTREPRENEUR HOPES
WILL BE A NEW ADDITION
TO AN ANCIENT TRADITION.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME'S NEAL HOFFMAN
FROM CINCINNATI, OHIO,
AND I'M HERE ASKING FOR $150,000
FOR 10% OF MY COMPANY.
NOW, SHARKS,
THINK ABOUT THE HOLIDAY SEASON.
THE SMELL OF CHRISTMAS TREES
IS IN THE AIR,
YOU HEAR "JINGLE BELLS"
PLAYING ON THE RADIO,
AND YOU'RE LITERALLY
COUNTING DOWN THE DAYS
UNTIL SANTA
COMES TO YOUR HOUSE.
IT SOUNDS WONDERFUL,
DOESN'T IT?
AND IT IS...
UNLESS YOU'RE JEWISH.
[ CHUCKLES ]
CHRISTMASTIME IS THE HARDEST
TIME TO BE A JEWISH CHILD.
BUT JUST BECAUSE OUR RELIGION'S
OVER 5,000 YEARS OLD
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE CAN'T ADD
SOME MORE "FUNUKKAH"
TO HANUKKAH.
INTRODUCING
THE MENSCH ON A BENCH.
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
OH, LORD.
THE MENSCH ON A BENCH IS
THE NEW JEWISH FAMILY TRADITION,
DESIGNED TO BRING MORE FUN AND
MORE MEMORIES TO YOUR HOUSEHOLD.
EVERY MENSCH ON A BENCH PACKAGE
COMES WITH A 12-INCH MENSCH,
HIS VERY OWN BENCH,
AND A HARDCOVER BOOK THAT TELLS
THE STORY OF MOSHE THE MENSCH.
A MENSCH IS A DO-GOODER.
IT'S WHAT YOU WANT YOUR CHILDREN
TO GROW UP TO BE.
AND THE MENSCH ON A BENCH
WOULD BECOME THE CENTERPIECE
OF YOUR HOLIDAY TRADITION.
IT WILL WATCH OVER
YOUR MENORAH
AND HOLD YOUR SHAMMASH,
OR YOUR LEADER CANDLE.
NOW, SHARKS, I UNDERSTAND
YOU HAVE A LOT OF PLACES
YOU COULD PUT YOUR MONEY
THIS HOLIDAY SEASON,
BUT NONE OF THEM HOLD A CANDLE
TO THE MENSCH ON A BENCH.
SO, WHO WANTS TO "GELT" TOGETHER
AND MAKE SOME MENSCHES?
WELL, HOW DID YOU COME UP
WITH THIS IDEA?
SO, I AM PART
OF AN INTERFAITH MARRIAGE,
AND WE GO THROUGH
THE DECEMBER DILEMMA EVERY YEAR.
WE'RE RAISING THE BOYS
JEWISH.
AND WE WERE
WALKING THROUGH A STORE,
AND MY SON ASKED
FOR AN ELF ON A SHELF,
AND I SAID, "DUDE, WE'RE JEWS.
WE DON'T DO ELVES ON SHELVES."
"DUDE."
OKAY?
WE DO MENSCHES ON BENCHES.
AND THE IDEA JUST HIT ME
LIKE -- LIKE LIGHTNING.
SO I WENT BACK,
I WROTE THE STORY OF,
WHY WOULD YOU NEED THE MENSCH?
AND EACH NIGHT IN THE STORY,
WE INTRODUCE
A DIFFERENT JEWISH TRADITION.
SO, THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
IS REALLY BEHIND THIS.
IT'S AN EDUCATIONAL TOOL.
CAN I SEE THE PACKAGING?
I DON'T WANT TO SELL
A SEASONAL PRODUCT.
I WANT TO SELL
A SEASONAL BRAND.
AND I'M A HUGE FAN OF YOURS,
KEVIN.
AND I KNOW
SOME OF THE THINGS YOU HATE.
YOU HATE INVENTORY.
HE HATES EVERYTHING, NEAL.
O'Leary: BUT, NEAL, YOU KNOW
THERE'S AN INVENTORY ISSUE,
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO HAVE
THE PRODUCT THERE FOR THOSE
THAT WANT TO BUY IT, BUT YOU'VE
GOT TO GUESSTIMATE RIGHT
HOW MANY ARE GOING
TO BE THERE TO BUY IT.
SO, WHAT I'VE DONE
WITH THE RETAILERS THIS YEAR IS,
THEY ARE BUYING IT
F.O.B. CHINA,
SO THE RETAILERS TAKE POSSESSION
OF ALL THE INVENTORY.
WE'RE NOT TAKING THE RISK
ON THE INVENTORY.
WELL, TELL US
ABOUT SALES LAST YEAR
VERSUS WHO'S GONNA PLAY WITH YOU
THIS YEAR.
SURE.
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MYSELF.
I'M A FORMER
HASBRO TOY EXECUTIVE.
OOH.
I'M NOT JUST A CRAZY JEWISH GUY
COMING OUT HERE.
SO, YOU'RE STILL WORKING?
PART-TIME.
I WORK THREE DAYS A WEEK.
I DO TWO DAYS ON MENSCH.
I'M READY,
IF I GET A DEAL TODAY,
TO QUIT MY JOB
AND DO THIS FULL TIME.
SO, WE CREATED IT,
RAISED $22,000 ON KICKSTARTER,
AND I TOLD MY WIFE,
"LET'S MAKE 1,000."
SO, I SOLD
MY FULL 1,000 I MADE,
AND THEN SOLD ANOTHER PRE-ORDERS
FOR ANOTHER 1,000 LAST YEAR.
NEAL, WHAT DID YOU SELL THEM
FOR? WHAT DO THEY COST?
THEY COST $7.45 TO MAKE.
WHAT DO THE RETAILERS
SELL THEM FOR?
THE BIG-BOX
WILL BE OUT AT $29.99,
AND THE SPECIALTY
WILL BE AT $34.99.
THIS YEAR, WE WILL BE
IN BED BATH & BEYOND,
TARGET, BARNES & NOBLES,
MICHAELS, TOYS "R" US.
WE ARE GOING TO DO $930,000
IN SALES THIS YEAR
ON 60,000 UNITS.
SO WE ANTICIPATE
MAKING $250,000 IN PROFIT.
CAN WE SEE THE BOOK
THAT'S INSIDE THE PACKAGE, NEAL?
Greiner: [ Laughing ]
HE NEEDS TO BE GOOD-LOOKING.
O'Leary: HE IS A SCARY-LOOKING
GUY, I GOT TO TELL YOU.
Corcoran:
YEAH, DEFINITELY.
HE'S NOT A FUN-LOOKING GUY.
COULD HE HAVE A SON?
HEY, IT'S NOT LIKE SANTA'S
A GOOD-LOOKING GUY.
YOU TAKE HIM OUT OF THE PACKAGE,
AND HE IS ON HIS BENCH ALREADY.
Hoffman: ABSOLUTELY.
O'Leary: SO -- SO, NEAL,
YOU'RE ASKING FOR A VALUE,
FROM ME AS A SHARK,
THAT ANTICIPATES
YOU'LL BE SUCCESSFUL GOING
BEYOND MENSCH ON A BENCH SKU,
THAT SOMEHOW
IT'S GOING TO GROW INTO A BRAND.
AND I THINK
THAT'S WHERE I'M HAVING
A LITTLE CHALLENGE
WITH THE LEAP OF FAITH.
SO, EVEN -- EVEN IF WE JUST GROW
THE MENSCH ON A BENCH BRAND
AND WE DRIVE DOWN
THE COST OF GOODS 10%,
WE CAN MAKE $500,000
IN PROFIT NEXT YEAR.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO WITH THE
$150,000 TO CONTINUE DEVELOPING?
I THINK, FOR NEXT YEAR,
DEVELOPING AN APP.
AN APP?
HAVE YOU SEEN ELF YOURSELF, THE
APP WHERE YOU PUT YOUR FACE --
YEAH, BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE COMPANY THAT DEVELOPED THAT
SPENDS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON THAT.
I KNOW THE GUYS
BEHIND THAT.
I GUESS
WHAT YOU'RE TELLING ME
IS THAT YOU JUST WANT TO USE
THE MONEY FOR MARKETING.
WELL, I THINK THE MARKETING
IS TAKING CARE OF ITSELF.
WHAT I WANT TO DO IS FIGURE OUT
WAYS TO EXPAND THE I.P.
THERE'S NOT AN I.P.
IN THE JEWISH COMMUNITY.
THERE'S FROSTY,
THERE'S RUDOLPH, THERE'S ELVES,
AND THAT'S WHAT I WANT
TO DEVELOP, BECAUSE I --
O'Leary: NEAL, IT SEEMS YOU WANT
TO TAKE YOUR POTENTIAL $250,000
TO $500,000 IN PROFIT
AND PUT IT INTO
A WHOLE BUNCH OF ENTERPRISES
THAT MAY NOT HAVE ANYWHERE NEAR
THE METRICS OF SUCCESS
THAT THIS THING
SEEMS TO ALREADY HAVE.
I-I DON'T --
I DON'T BUY INTO THAT.
I THINK WHAT YOU SHOULD BE DOING
IS NOT QUITTING YOUR DAY JOB,
CALLING THIS WHAT IT IS --
A UNIQUE HOBBY FOR A COUPLE
OF MONTHS OF THE YEAR --
AND TRYING TO EXTRACT OUT OF IT
IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS
A MILLION BUCKS FOR YOU.
I DON'T REALLY SEE IT
AS AN INVESTMENT.
I DON'T SEEN MENSCH ON A BENCH
BEING A $10 MILLION TOY.
I REALLY DON'T. AND LOOK,
I-I-I COME FROM YOUR SPACE.
SURE.
I WORKED AT MATTEL
FOR A WHILE.
WHAT YOU'VE DONE
IS REMARKABLE,
JUST GETTING A PLUSH
INTO RETAIL.
BUT I'M NOT BUYING INTO THE BIG,
UH, YOU KNOW, MENSCHY THE --
THE -- THE REINDEER, AND --
AND APPS AND ALL THAT STUFF.
I'M -- I'M NOT THERE
FOR THAT.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
Cuban: MY ISSUE RIGHT NOW --
WE KEEP ON ASKING YOU HOW YOU'RE
GONNA TURN IT INTO A COMPANY,
AND YOU KEEP ON TALKING ABOUT
WANTING TO HAVE I.P.
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU WANT TO
GROW YOURSELF INTO BANKRUPTCY.
IT -- IT'S GREAT
TO HAVE BIG AMBITIONS,
RIGHT,
BUT YOU GOT TO GET THERE.
YOU'VE GOT THE CART
BEFORE THE HORSE.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
Herjavec: NEAL, YOU KNOW,
THE CROATIAN COMMUNITY
IS VERY AKIN
TO THE JEWISH COMMUNITY.
I LOVE THE IDEA.
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO EXTEND IT.
I THINK THAT THE OTHER THINGS
YOU'VE TRIED TO THROW AT US
MIGHT BE THREE, FOUR YEARS
IN THE FUTURE.
OKAY.
I THINK BETWEEN NOW AND THEN,
YOU'VE GOT TO BUILD OUT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT I LIKE THAT PATH.
I WANT TO MAXIMIZE THE SALES FOR
THIS FOR THAT HOLIDAY SEASON.
YOU KNOW,
THERE'S AN OLD YIDDISH SAYING
THAT SAYS
"HOW IT BEGINS IS HOW IT ENDS."
IT'S SELLING VERY WELL.
LET'S KEEP DOING THAT.
OKAY.
ARE YOU OPEN TO THAT?
I AM OPEN TO THAT.
SO, THEN, ROBERT AND I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE YOU AN OFFER,
'CAUSE I ALSO --
I LOVE THE IDEA
OF TEACHING GOOD VALUES
AND MORALS.
AND -- AND I SEE THAT
THERE IS A NEED IN THE
MARKETPLACE FOR THIS.
WE'RE GONNA OFFER YOU
$150,000,
BUT WE WANT 30%.
YOU KNOW, I FEEL LIKE I CAME IN
HERE WITH A VERY FAIR VALUATION.
WITH $1 MILLION IN SALES
COMING THIS YEAR,
WE'RE $250,000 PROFITABILITY
THIS YEAR.
WE'RE GONNA DO $500,000
NEXT YEAR.
THAT'S WITHOUT
ANY OF THE OTHER STUFF.
NEAL, YOU GOT TO LEAVE
WITH A SHARK.
THERE'S TWO SHARKS.
LET ME TELL YOU --
I MEAN,
I'M IN WITH LORI ON THAT.
YEP.
LOVE TO BE PART OF THE DEAL.
THERE IS A LOT OF RISK.
I MEAN, I THINK YOU KNOW THAT.
I THINK IT'S A FAIR VALUATION,
ASSUMING NOTHING CHANGES.
I THINK
YOU HAVEN'T REALLY ARTICULATED
HOW YOU'RE GONNA
GROW THE BRAND.
HERE WOULD BE
MY COUNTEROFFER,
'CAUSE I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S SOME RISK TO YOU.
$150,000 FOR 15%,
AND I WILL PERSONALLY GUARANTEE
YOUR $150,000 BACK
IN THREE YEARS.
PERSONALLY.
IF I HAVE TO TAKE OUT
ANOTHER MORTGAGE ON MY HOUSE
TO GIVE THAT TO YOU,
I WILL.
WHOA.
NO, I -- I...
I WILL PUT THAT INTO THE
CONTRACT, MAKE IT RISK-FREE.
NEAL,
THAT'S NOT GONNA BE NECESSARY,
BECAUSE I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
A BETTER OFFER.
Narrator:
TWO SHARKS ARE OUT.
NEAL HAS AN OFFER ON THE TABLE
FROM LORI AND ROBERT
FOR $150,000 FOR 30%
OF MENSCH ON A BENCH,
BUT BARBARA
MAY OUTDO THEIR OFFER.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
$150,000 FOR 20%.
THAT'S A LOT BETTER.
I DON'T NEED
YOUR GUARANTEES.
BUT IT COMES WITH
A COUPLE OF CONTINGENCIES
THAT I THINK WOULD ACTUALLY
HELP YOUR PRODUCT.
I LOOK AT THIS BOOK,
AND I SEE A FRIENDLY GUY
WITH AN ADORABLE FACE.
I LOOK AT YOUR DOLL,
AND I SEE A NERVOUS OLD MAN.
OKAY.
TWO TOTALLY DIFFERENT FACES.
THE CONTINGENCIES ARE
THAT WE CAN REDRAW HIS FACE
SO THAT HE ACTUALLY LOOKS
FRIENDLY AND HUGGABLE...
OKAY.
...'CAUSE HE DOESN'T,
ALL RIGHT?
HE LOOKS DUSTY,
LIKE I WANT TO RETIRE HIM, OKAY?
YEAH. THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
AND ALSO,
WHEN I LOOK THROUGH YOUR BOOK,
IT ENDS WITH 10 RULES.
YEP.
KIDS HATE RULES.
IT'S SUCH
A NEGATIVE NOTE
THAT I HAVE THE ABILITY
TO REWRITE THE BOOK.
BY THE TIME BARBARA'S FINISHED,
THE MENSCH IS GONNA BE CATHOLIC.
THOSE ARE THE TWO --
[ LAUGHTER ]
MY WIFE IS CATHOLIC,
SO THAT'S WONDERFUL!
I THINK YOU'VE GONE IN
A GOOD DIRECTION WITH THE BOOK.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
TO BARBARA,
I MEAN, YOU CAN'T REWRITE
THE ENTIRE THING.
SOMETHING'S WORKING, RIGHT?
NO, JUST SOME --
JUST CHANGE IT A BIT.
I MEAN, I-I THINK SHE HAS
A GREAT POINT WITH THE FACE.
THE GUY IN THE BOOK
IS VERY JOVIAL.
MM-HMM.
THE DOLL GUY
I-IS A LITTLE, UH...
WE CAN WORK ON THAT.
NOT AS FRIENDLY.
YEAH.
WE CAN WORK ON THAT.
WHAT A CREATIVE IDEA.
THANK YOU, ROBERT.
[ CHUCKLES ]
YOUR COUNTER, NEAL,
WAS $150,000 FOR 15%.
WITH GUARANTEED PAYBACK
OVER THREE YEARS.
DONE.
I'M...
THERE YOU GO.
THERE YOU GO!
COME ON IN.
MAZEL TOV!
HEY!
[ LAUGHS ]
THANK YOU GUYS VERY MUCH.
GOOD LUCK, NEAL.
DO WE GET TO KEEP
THE BIG GUY?
[ LAUGHTER ]
THANK YOU.
I'M GOING IN MONDAY,
I'M QUITTING MY JOB,
AND I'M A FULL-TIME
MENSCH ON A BENCH EMPLOYEE.
SO I-I COULD NOT BE HAPPIER.
Narrator: IN SEASON FIVE,
MORRI CHOWAIKI MADE A DEAL
WITH DAYMOND JOHN
FOR HIS INTERFAITH
HOLIDAY PRODUCT,
THE HANUKKAH TREE TOPPER.
KISS ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Narrator: LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
[ CAR HORN HONKS ]
Chowaiki:
PARTNERING WITH DAYMOND
WAS THE BEST THING I COULD HAVE
EVER DONE FOR MY BUSINESS.
HEY, MAN.
WHAT'S UP, MORRI?
WHAT'S UP, MAN?
OH! GREAT TO SEE YOU, BUDDY.
DAYMOND IMMEDIATELY SAW
MY PRODUCT AND BRAND
AS A VALUABLE
LICENSING OPPORTUNITY.
KURT ADLER'S
HANDLING EVERYTHING FOR US.
THIS IS A LICENSING
DREAM COME TRUE.
John:
WITHIN WEEKS OF DOING OUR DEAL,
WE CLOSED A BIG LICENSING DEAL
WITH KURT S. ADLER.
THEY ARE ONE OF THE LARGEST
IMPORTERS AND DISTRIBUTORS
OF HOLIDAY DECORATIONS
IN THE INDUSTRY.
YOU HAVE TO SEE
THIS SHOWROOM.
IT'S LIKE WILLY WONKA'S
CHOCOLATE FACTORY
MEETS CHRISTMAS.
COME ON.
I MEAN,
YOU ARE GONNA LOVE THIS THING.
HERE IT IS.
UH-HUH.
LOOK AT THIS.
WOW.
Chowaiki: THE KURT S. ADLER
SHOWROOM HAS GOT TO BE
ONE OF THE IMPRESSIVE THINGS
I'VE EVER SEEN.
I HAVE A GOOD FEELING THIS IS
THE HANUKKAH TREE TOPPERS.
OH, LOOK AT THIS.
AND THEN, TO SEE MY HANUKKAH
TREE TOPPERS UP THERE --
IT'S A SURREAL EXPERIENCE.
WOW, LOOK, IT'S CHRISTMAS.
HOWARD!
HEY,
NICE TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
John: KURT S. ADLER ALREADY
SELLS TO ALL THE BIG-BOX CHAINS,
SO THEY'VE TAKEN OUT
ALL THE HASSLE FOR US.
WE'VE HAD A GREAT RESPONSE
THIS YEAR FROM YOUR PRODUCT,
AND WE EXPECT IT
TO CONTINUE.
John: WITH OUR LICENSING
AGREEMENT, THEY'VE ALREADY
TAKEN THE HANUKKAH TREE TOPPER
INTO TOYS "R" US,
AND THEY'RE EXPANDING OUR
FOOTPRINT IN BED BATH & BEYOND.
AND HERE'S SOME THINGS
FOR OUR 2015 CATALOG.
THEY'VE TAKEN OVER DESIGN,
MANUFACTURING, ADVERTISING.
YOU NAME IT,
THEY'RE DOING IT.
AND MORRI AND I
GET A ROYALTY
OFF OF EVERY
HANUKKAH TREE TOPPER THEY SELL.
NOW I GET TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT'S NEXT.
BEFORE AIRING
ON "SHARK TANK,"
IT TOOK 3 YEARS
TO REACH $150,000 IN SALES.
SINCE MAKING A DEAL
ON "SHARK TANK" ONE YEAR AGO,
WE'VE ALREADY DOUBLED OUR SALES
TO $300,000.
WE'RE BECOMING A HOUSEHOLD NAME
IN THE ORNAMENT BUSINESS
AND MAKING INTERFAITH FAMILIES
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY SMILE.
John:
IN THE SPIRIT OF GIVING,
MORRI AND I DECIDED TO MAKE
A DONATION TO TOYS FOR TOTS,
BECAUSE EVERY CHILD DESERVES TO
BE ABLE TO ENJOY THE HOLIDAYS.
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS AN EASIER WAY
TO ADD SPARKLE TO THE HOLIDAYS.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS NATHAN SHAFFER,
AND I'M FROM HENDERSON, NEVADA.
MY COMPANY IS EVE DROP,
AND I'M SEEKING $75,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 20% EQUITY.
CAN ANY OF YOU
THINK OF SOMEONE YOU KNOW
WHO LOVES
HANGING CHRISTMAS LIGHTS?
[ LAUGHS ]
I DOUBT IT.
IT'S A SERIOUSLY
TEDIOUS TASK.
FIRST, YOU HAVE TO GO
DRAG OUT ALL THE STUFF, RIGHT?
DOES THIS LOOK FAMILIAR?
THEN YOU'VE GOT TO SCALE UP
A RICKETY LADDER
AND DANGLE
FROM THE SIDE OF YOUR ROOF
JUST TRYING
TO INSTALL THESE THINGS.
IT TAKES FOREVER,
JUST TO TAKE THEM DOWN
A FEW SHORT WEEKS LATER.
IF ONLY THERE WAS A BETTER WAY,
RIGHT?
INTRODUCING EVE DROP.
ONCE YOU HANG YOUR CHRISTMAS
LIGHTS WITH EVE DROP,
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO IT AGAIN
YEAR AFTER YEAR.
EVE DROP IS THE ONLY PRODUCT
ON THE MARKET
WHICH ALLOWS YOU
TO QUICKLY MOVE YOUR LIGHTS
FROM STORAGE MODE
TO DISPLAY MODE.
LET ME SHOW YOU HOW.
[ LAUGHS ]
AND WHEN THE SEASON'S OVER,
NO BIG DEAL.
YOU CAN PUT AWAY THOSE LIGHTS
FASTER THAN IT TAKES
TO POLISH OFF A GLASS
OF AUNT EDNA'S EGG NOG.
OBSERVE.
NAILED IT.
SO, WHICH OF YOU SHARKS
WOULD LIKE TO PARTNER WITH ME
AND HELP AMERICA
SPEND LESS TIME DECORATING
AND MORE TIME ENJOYING
THE HOLIDAYS WITH EVE DROP?
NATHAN,
TELL ME HOW IT WORKS.
SO, I BUILT THIS DISPLAY TO OPEN
UP SO THAT IT COULD FAN OUT,
AND WE COULD SHOW YOU GUYS
BASICALLY HOW IT WORKS.
THIS CAP SPINS OFF.
IT HAS A GROOVE.
YOU PLACE THE LIGHT
THROUGH THE GROOVE,
AND THEN
YOU SPIN THE CAP DOWN.
IT APPLIES
JUST A LITTLE PRESSURE
TO PUSH IT AGAINST THE BASE,
WHICH HOLDS IT IN PLACE.
IF YOU WANT TO LOWER IT,
QUARTER-TWIST LOWERS IT.
SO, YOU STILL HAVE TO
GET UP ON THE LADDER
TO RAISE THE LIGHTS UP?
THAT'S OUR SECOND SKU
THAT WE'RE PUTTING INTO STORES,
AND THAT'S CALLED
THE EVE DROP POLE ADAPTER.
SO, YOU JUST CAP IT FROM --
YOU'RE STANDING ON THE GROUND,
YOU GIVE IT A QUARTER-TWIST,
AND THEN IT CAN COME DOWN.
QUARTER-TWIST BACK,
AND IT STAYS.
OH, THAT'S KIND OF COOL.
SO, NATHAN, THAT'S PART
OF THE DEAL, THAT POLE,
OR YOU PAY EXTRA FOR THAT?
YOU PAY EXTRA.
IT'S A SEPARATE SKU.
GIVE US YOUR NUMBERS,
NATHAN.
SALES TO DATE ARE $4,500.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH, MY GOD.
YOU MEAN FOR THE DAY TODAY?
NATHAN, LIGHTS OUT.
THE -- YEAH.
THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE
ANY PENDING PURCHASE ORDERS.
HOW LONG WAS THAT PERIOD
FOR THE $4,500?
WELL, THERE'S AN EXPLANATION
FOR THAT.
THERE'S A REASON
THOSE NUMBERS --
THERE ALWAYS IS.
THAT NUMBER WAS ACTUALLY RAISED
VIA KICKSTARTER,
A CAMPAIGN THAT I THREW
JUST AFTER THE CHRISTMAS SEASON
JUST TO HELP GET SOME MONEY
TO HELP OFFSET
SOME OF MY PRODUCTION COSTS,
RIGHT?
SO, FROM THERE,
I TOOK THAT MONEY
AND I HELPED TO, UH,
PRODUCE SOME OF THE MOLDS
THAT I WOULD NEED
TO MAKE MY PARTS.
SO, I DID THAT OVERSEAS.
THE PARTS
HAVEN'T YET ARRIVED,
WHICH IS WHY THE SALES ARE
THE WAY THAT THEY ARE,
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU.
NATHAN,
IT WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA
FOR YOU TO HAND OUT
THE PACKAGING
SO WE CAN SEE IT
AND GET OUR HANDS ON IT.
LET'S DO IT.
OH, SO --
SO THIS IS THE PRODUCT.
HOW MUCH
DOES THIS RETAIL FOR?
$9.99 FOR THE LIGHT HANGERS.
AND THAT RETAILS FOR?
$3.99.
AND THAT'S FOR NOW.
NATHAN, HOW MANY OF THESE
DO I NEED FOR AN AVERAGE HOME?
ABOUT FIVE PACKS.
THAT'S NOT CHEAP.
THAT'S $40 OR $50,
PLUS THE POLE.
IT'S $40 OR $50.
IT'S A ONE-TIME EXPENSE,
RATHER THAN BUYING CLIPS
YEAR AFTER YEAR.
'CAUSE YOU GUYS KNOW
THOSE DON'T LAST.
NATHAN, WHEN WE HAD
OUR CHRISTMAS LIGHTS UP --
AND MY MOTHER
WENT WHOLE HOG
PUTTING THEM
ON OUR UGLY, LITTLE HOUSE --
IT WAS THE HIGH POINT
OF HER YEAR.
YEAH.
SADLY FOR YOU,
SHE HAD A BETTER IDEA.
SHE DROVE TWO SETS OF NAILS
BEHIND THE EAVES.
AND WHEN IT WAS
CHRISTMASTIME,
SHE DROPPED THE LIGHTS
DOWN TO THE LOWER SET.
AND WHEN CHRISTMAS
WAS OVER,
SHE LIFTED THEM UP
TO THE HIGHER SET.
DOES YOUR MOM NEED A JOB?
WAIT A SECOND.
Greiner: SO FAR, SHE DID
EXACTLY WHAT HE'S DOING.
NATHAN, WE'VE GOT TO LITIGATE
BARB'S MOM!
HIS ARE EASIER.
YOU KNOW WHAT, NATHAN?
BECAUSE BARB'S MOM
WAS SMARTER THAN YOU, I'M OUT.
OOH.
THANK YOU, MARK.
ARE YOU WORKING THIS
FULL-TIME,
OR DO YOU HAVE ANOTHER,
GOOD-PAYING JOB?
I HAVE ANOTHER, GOOD-PAYING JOB.
I WORK IN OUTSIDE SALES.
I SELL JANITORIAL
AND SANITARY PRODUCTS.
I'M ACTUALLY VERY SUCCESSFUL
IN SALES.
LOOK, LET ME CLEAR THE FIELD.
I HATE THIS IDEA A LOT.
IT'S VERY SEASONAL.
I THINK RETAIL'S
GONNA BE VERY CHALLENGING.
AND BECAUSE I HATE IT SO MUCH,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, KEVIN.
NATHAN, WHERE ARE YOU
IN TERMS OF THE BUSINESS?
RIGHT NOW, I AM, UH, WAITING
FOR MY INVENTORY TO ARRIVE.
HOW MUCH INVENTORY
HAVE YOU BOUGHT?
$30,000.
OKAY.
AND DO YOU HAVE
ANY OF IT PRE-SOLD?
YES, I DO.
I HAVE P.O.s TO GO INTO A COUPLE
DIFFERENT CHAINS OF STORES.
THE TOTAL P.O.s AT THIS POINT
ARE $3,500.
IT'S GOING
TO 12 DIFFERENT STORES.
OKAY, I'M NOT -- I'M NOT
AS GOOD AT MATH AS BARBARA,
BUT YOU HAVE $30,000
YOU'VE BOUGHT,
AND YOU'VE ONLY SOLD
$3,500.
WHY DID YOU ORDER
SO MUCH AT ONE TIME
WITHOUT HAVING
PURCHASE ORDERS?
I-I-I GUESS THAT'S
THE CONFUSION, THOUGH.
I'M ANTICIPATING
THE CHRISTMAS SEASON.
I ACTUALLY DID GET APPROACHED
BY SkyMall.
THEY WERE INTERESTED.
THEY VETTED IT.
THEY WANTED IT
IN THEIR CHRISTMAS CATALOG.
I ACTUALLY ENDED UP
DECIDING NOT TO DO IT
BECAUSE I ONLY HAD ENOUGH MONEY
TO BUY THE $30,000 IN INVENTORY
AND, TO BE HONEST WITH YOU,
I KNOW I'M GONNA SELL IT
AT A HIGHER MARGIN ELSEWHERE.
Greiner: BUT WAIT A MINUTE.
THAT DOES NOT MAKE SENSE.
OH, MY FRIEND.
MY FRIEND -- NATHAN -- OKAY.
ONCE YOU'VE FACTORED
IN THE CO-OP --
NATHAN, NATHAN, NATHAN,
RULE NUMBER ONE...
YES.
...WHEN YOU'RE STARTING OUT,
NEVER SNEER AT AN ORDER,
MY FRIEND.
YES.
THE SALES GUY IN ME
REALLY GETS IRRITABLE
WHEN SOMEONE TURNS DOWN
AN ORDER FROM ANYONE.
I'M OUT.
THAT'S FINE, ROBERT. THE REASON
I DID THAT IS 'CAUSE --
BUT DOES THAT BOTHER YOU
THAT HE JUST DROPPED OUT?
YOU JUST KEPT GOING ON.
NOT EVEN A PAUSE.
I WANT TO PARTNER
WITH THE PERSON
THAT BELIEVES IN ME
AND THE PRODUCT.
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS YOU.
YES.
YOU'RE NOT PERSUASIVE.
IS THAT RIGHT?
I THINK YO-- YES, VERY MUCH SO.
I THINK YOU --
I AM THE SALESMAN OF THE YEAR
FOR MY COMPANY.
WELL --
I HAVE BEEN
TWO STRAIGHT YEARS.
BUT I HAVE A FULL-TIME JOB.
I HAVE FOUR KIDS AT HOME
AND MY WIFE,
AND I HAVE
A LOT OF RESPONSIBILITIES.
I DON'T MEAN
FOR THAT TO BE AN EXCUSE --
BUT I MISTRUST
YOUR JUDGMENT.
I THINK
EVERY GREAT ENTREPRENEUR
HAS TO BE A GREAT SALESMAN
TO GET THEIR PRODUCT SOLD,
BUT THEY ALSO HAVE TO HAVE
INNATE JUDGMENT
OF WHAT TO SPEND,
WHAT TO ORDER,
WHEN TO HOLD BACK,
WHEN TO PUSH FORWARD.
I'M NOT SO SURE
YOU'VE GOT THAT.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT I PROJECT
ALL THE TIME WITH MY NUMBERS.
I'M IN SALES,
AND I HIT MY NUMBERS EVERY TIME.
BUT PROJECTED WRONGLY
ON YOUR OWN BUSINESS.
I BELIEVE I DID NOT.
THAT'S WHAT
THE NEXT EIGHT WEEKS ARE FOR.
I HAVE 65 DISPLAYS COMING.
I'M PLANNING ON
PLACING ALL 65.
SELLING IT ONLINE,
AND THE MARGIN ONLINE IS 80%.
I HAVE AN E-COMMERCE SITE
SET UP, ALL READY TO GO.
I HAVE AMAZON
WITH THE PRODUCTS LOADED.
INTERESTING. YOU'RE SELLING ME
NOW, YOU KNOW THAT?
FOR THE FIRST TIME,
I'M SEEING THE SALESMAN IN YOU.
MAYBE YOU JUST
SAVED YOURSELF FROM DEATH.
LET ME THINK ABOUT THIS.
OKAY.
REALLY?
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO,
LORI?
YOU HAVE A HISTORY
OF TAKING REAL CRAP
AND TURNING IT INTO GOLD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THANK YOU, KEVIN!
WOW.
NATHAN,
I THINK IT HAS POTENTIAL
AT SOME POINT DOWN THE ROAD
TO MAYBE BE A HERO.
RIGHT NOW,
I THINK IT'S VERY CHALLENGING.
I THINK YOU HAVE
A LONG WAY TO GO
WITH THE PACKAGING, THE DISPLAY,
AND GETTING OUT THERE.
AND SO, FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S OKAY.
O'Leary: OKAY, NOW.
DOWN TO ONE SHARK.
BARBARA.
ON THE ONE HAND, I SEE A LOVELY
GUY THAT SAYS HE CAN SELL,
AND I SAW
A LITTLE BIT OF IT, ALL RIGHT?
I CAN SELL.
ON THE OTHER HAND, I DON'T THINK
YOUR PRODUCT SELLS ITSELF,
EVEN IF YOU COULD
GET IN THE DOOR.
SO, UNFORTUNATELY,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD LUCK, NATHAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
YOU GUYS.
GOOD LUCK.
HAVE A GOOD ONE.
IT'S KIND OF INTERESTING,
BECAUSE FOR THE LAST YEAR,
I'VE BEEN WANTING
TO MAKE IT ONTO "SHARK TANK."
I'VE WANTED TO BE IN THE TANK.
AND THEN,
WHEN YOU'RE IN THE TANK,
YOU WANT NOTHING MORE
TO JUST GET OUT OF THE TANK.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK IS
A PRODUCT INVENTED BY A TEENAGER
TO SOLVE A PROBLEM
SHE HAD AT HOME.
HELLO! MY NAME IS ANDREA CAO,
AND I AM 13 YEARS OLD.
HELLO. MY NAME'S HONG.
I'M ANDREA'S MOM.
WE ARE FROM SAN LUIS OBISPO,
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE THE CREATORS
OF THE Q-FLEX.
WE ARE SEEKING $20,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 20% OF OUR COMPANY.
I'M A NURSE.
I HAVE TO WORK LONG HOURS.
AND AFTER ONE WHOLE DAY
WORKING ON MY FEET,
I COME HOME SO SORE
I CAN BARELY MOVE.
AND GUESS WHO SHE TURNED TO.
THAT'S RIGHT, ME.
I WILL BEG ANDREA
TO MASSAGE MY BACK FOR ME.
AND I LOVE MY MOM, BUT I WAS
GETTING REALLY TIRED OF THAT.
SO I STARTED WONDERING,
WAS THERE ANY INEXPENSIVE,
EFFECTIVE WAY
FOR HER TO DO THIS
HERSELF?
THERE WASN'T,
SO THAT'S WHEN WE DECIDED
TO BECOME ENTREPRENEURS
AND MAKE ONE OURSELVES.
WE SPEND MONTHS DRAWING OUT,
PLANNING,
AND TESTING IT
TO PERFECTION,
AND FINALLY,
THE Q-FLEX WAS BORN.
THE Q-FLEX IS
A PERSONAL ACUPRESSURE SYSTEM
THAT IS DESIGNED
TO BE USED
ON YOUR SORE SPOTS
AND KNOTTED MUSCLES
TO RELIEVE TENSION
AND PAIN.
THIS AWESOME PRODUCT CAN
GIVE YOU A REALLY NICE MASSAGE
WITHOUT THOSE HUGE,
SCARY MASSAGE CHAIRS,
AND WITHOUT GOING TO
A PROFESSIONAL MASSAGE PARLOR
AND MAKING YOUR WALLET SORE,
TOO.
I MEAN,
YOU'RE ALREADY SORE ENOUGH.
AND THE BEST PART IS,
IS THAT YOU CAN TAKE THE Q-FLEX
ANYWHERE WITH YOU
BECAUSE IT'S SO LIGHTWEIGHT
AND PORTABLE.
SHARKS, WITH 65 MILLION PEOPLE
SUFFERING FROM BACK PAIN ALONE,
THERE IS A HUGE MARKET
FOR THIS.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS --
CHA-CHING!
SO, SHARKS,
COME WITH US,
AND LET'S FLEX OUR WAY
TO SUCCESS.
I HAVE SOME SAMPLES
TO PASS OUT FOR YOU GUYS.
Herjavec: COOL.
Greiner: GREAT.
ANDREA,
I THINK YOU'RE LYING TO US.
REALLY?
YEAH.
OH, NO.
YEAH. THERE'S --
THERE'S NO WAY YOU'RE 13.
Cuban: NO KIDDING.
OH.
VERY IMPRESSIVE.
THAT WAS
A FANTASTIC PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU.
HERE YOU GO.
SO, ONCE YOU GET BACK THERE,
I'M GONNA ASK YOU HOW WE USE IT,
BUT I'M ASSUMING
I JUST KIND OF, LIKE,
BEAT LORI ON THE BACK
A LITTLE BIT?
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
WELL, NO.
DO YOU LIKE IT?!
I KNOW!
SO, TELL ME HOW IT WORKS.
Andrea: OKAY, SO FIRST...
IT'S GREAT.
...YOU'RE GONNA GRIP
THE CUSHIONED GRIP,
AND THEN YOU'RE GONNA
PUT THE TIP OF THE Q-FLEX
ON THE AREA THAT IS SORE.
AND THEN YOU'RE GONNA PULL AND
RELEASE AND PULL AND RELEASE.
AND DO THAT A COUPLE TIMES,
AND THEN THAT'S WHAT --
THAT'S IT. YOU'RE DONE.
O'Leary: THAT'S IT?
ACTUALLY,
IT FEELS PRETTY GOOD.
Hong: SO, THE IDEA --
Corcoran: LET ME TELL YOU,
IT FEELS FABULOUS.
THANK YOU!
HAVE YOU SOLD ANY OF THESE?
YES, I'VE SOLD 800.
800.
800?
AND WHERE
WERE YOU SELLING THEM?
UM, I GO DOOR-TO-DOOR
SELLING THEM IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GOOD FOR YOU! YEAH!
I LOVE THAT.
Andrea: THANK YOU.
BAM!
AND FROM THERE,
WORD OF MOUTH SPREADS.
THEIR FRIENDS, UM,
COME AND BUY THEM FROM US,
AND THEN
THEY TELL THEIR FRIENDS.
HOW MUCH
DO YOU SELL THEM FOR?
FROM $25 TO $36.
HOW MUCH
DO THEY COST TO MAKE?
$4.50.
[ CHUCKLES ]
A CAPITALIST IS BORN!
Greiner: $25 TO $36.
YOU MAKE THEM HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES?
YES, WE DO.
AND DO YOU HAVE A WEBSITE
WHERE YOU CAN BUY THEM?
UH, WE'RE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON THAT.
ANDREA, DO YOU HAVE
A PATENT ON IT OR ANY...?
UM, WE ARE WORKING WITH AN
ATTORNEY TO FILE FOR A PATENT.
PATENT ATTORNEY
IS VERY EXPENSIVE.
ANDREA, FANTASTIC JOB
ON THE PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU.
I CAN'T TELL YOU, IN THE SIX
SEASONS, HOW MANY PEOPLE
STAND EXACTLY
WHERE YOU'RE STANDING,
AND WE ASK THEM,
"DO YOU HAVE ANY SALES?"
AND THEY COME UP
WITH A MILLION EXCUSES.
Cuban: YEP.
AND YOU SIMPLY WENT OUT, KNOCKED
DOOR-TO-DOOR, AND DID IT.
THANK YOU.
AND JUST CRUSHED IT.
YOU CRUSHED IT.
ABSOLUTELY FANTASTIC.
THANK YOU.
HERE'S THE CHALLENGE.
I-I DON'T USUALLY
ASK THIS QUESTION,
BUT WHAT'S THERE
TO STOP SOMEBODY
FROM KNOCKING YOU OFF
ON IT?
WELL, WE'VE WORKED VERY HARD ON,
UH, CREATING THE RIGHT ANGLE,
AND WE ACTUALLY ARE THE ONLY
PRODUCT THAT USES A SOLID,
SPECIALLY-FORMULATED,
BULLET-PROOF PLASTIC,
WHICH GIVES THE RIGHT AMOUNT
OF FLEX COMBINED WITH THE ANGLE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY RESEARCH
THAT SAYS THIS WORKS WELL
OR IS CERTIFIED
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT?
ACTUALLY, I'M A NURSE,
AND THE IDEA BEHIND THIS IS,
WHEN OUR BODY HAS PAIN,
BLOOD FLOW
TO THAT PROBLEM AREA.
SO BY STIMULATING
THOSE PRESSURE POINTS,
YOU ACTUALLY INCREASE
THE BLOOD FLOW TO THE AREA.
OH, I SEE. SO --
SO IF YOU MASSAGE THE AREA,
YOU GET MORE BLOOD FLOW,
AND YOU GET MORE ENERGY.
YES.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO
WITH THE MONEY?
WE WOULD USE THE MONEY
TO BUY A STAINLESS-STEEL MOLD
SO WE COULD MAKE
A LOT MORE.
AND, ALSO, WE'RE NOT JUST HERE
FOR THE INVESTMENT --
AND WHAT WOULD THAT COST,
IF YOU DON'T MIND MY ASKING?
$20,000.
AND DO YOU MIND IF I ASK,
DID YOU MENTION EARLIER
HOW MUCH MONEY
YOU PUT IN THE COMPANY SO FAR?
WE HAVE INITIALLY PUT $10,000
AND OVERALL, $20,000.
THAT'S A BIG INVESTMENT
IN YOUR 13-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER,
WHO WAS PROBABLY 12
AT THE TIME.
AND WHAT WERE YOUR TOTAL SALES
IN DOLLARS?
AROUND $20,000.
SO, YOU MADE SOME GOOD MONEY,
THEN.
YOU'VE -- BUT YOU'VE --
HAVE YOU PAID YOUR MOM BACK?
UH, WE'RE STILL
A LITTLE BIT UNDER.
YEAH.
JUST A LITTLE BIT UNDER.
SO YOU'VE GOT
MOST OF YOUR MONEY BACK ALREADY.
YES.
OOH! I LOVE WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
GOOD FOR YOU.
LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION.
YOU'RE 13.
YOU MUST BE IN GRADE 7 OR 8?
8, YEAH.
OKAY, YOU'RE IN 8th GRADE,
AND YOUR MOTHER'S
A FULL-TIME NURSE.
SO, WHICH ONE OF YOU IS QUITTING
YOUR JOB TO RUN Q-FLEX?
HER.
IS THAT RIGHT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
BECAUSE I'M OKAY
WITH YOU QUITTING SCHOOL.
THAT WOULD SHOW ME
COMMITMENT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Greiner: THAT'D BE A MISTAKE.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM -- THAT'S
THE PROBLEM WITH YOUR DEAL.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW,
IT'S A PRODUCT.
IT'S COME OUT OF A NEED,
AN INNOVATION.
BUT TO RUN A BUSINESS
AND TURN THIS INTO A BUSINESS
REQUIRES FULL TIME.
UH, I COULD QUIT, BEC--
I WAS ENGINEER BEFORE.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MAKE YOU
A BUSINESSPERSON, THOUGH.
DID YOU SAY
YOU WERE AN ENGINEER?
YES,
WHAT IS YOUR BACKGROUND?
I-I WAS AN ENGINEER BEFORE.
YOU WERE?
AND I LOST MY HUSBAND
SEVEN YEARS AGO
DUE TO A HEART ATTACK.
SO DECIDED
TO REACH OUT TO PEOPLE,
KIND OF -- KIND OF
HELP PEOPLE DIRECTLY.
AND SO DECIDED
TO QUIT MY ENGINEERING JOB
AND GO TO --
GO TO A NURSING SCHOOL.
NOW I'M AN R.N.
WORKING FULL-TIME IN A HOSPITAL.
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU,
I DON'T KNOW THE BUSINESS SIDE.
WE ARE HERE
LOOKING FOR A MENTOR.
I APPLAUD YOU TO WANTING
TO GIVE BACK, TO BE A NURSE.
I MEAN, THAT'S PHENOMENAL.
IT'S ONE OF THE HARDEST JOBS
IN THE WORLD.
BUT ON A DAY-BY-DAY BASIS,
YOU KNOW,
I-I CAN'T CALL YOU EVERY DAY
AND TALK ABOUT
HOW WE'RE GONNA SELL IT.
THIS IS A HOBBY
FOR YOUR FAMILY.
IT'S NOT A BUSINESS YET.
IT'S A PRODUCT.
THE KID CAN'T QUIT SCHOOL.
YOU SHOULDN'T QUIT YOUR JOB
IN THE CURRENT SITUATION.
I DON'T WANT TO DIMINISH IT,
BUT IT'S, IN MY VIEW,
NOT INVESTABLE.
I'M OUT.
Greiner:
I FEEL SO BAD SAYING THIS.
I USED TO SELL A PRODUCT
THAT WAS VERY SIMILAR.
IT HAD THE SIMILAR SHAPE.
Cuban: WELL, LORI,
HOW DID YOU DO WITH IT?
I THOUGHT IT WAS
A BRILLIANT, BRILLIANT PRODUCT.
UM, IT WAS
A CHALLENGING PRODUCT TO SELL.
WHY?
IT ENDED TRAGICALLY.
I'M NOT REALLY POSITIVE WHY IT
DIDN'T WORK, 'CAUSE I LOVED IT.
SO, AS MUCH AS I LOVE YOU
AND WOULD LOVE TO INVEST IN YOU,
I FEAR FOR THE PRODUCT
AS NOT BEING SOMETHING
THAT WE COULD MAKE SUCCESSFUL.
SO, FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
LORI, DO YOU WORRY THAT
THEY WON'T GET A PATENT FOR IT?
I DO. I-I WOULD TELL HONESTLY,
I WOULDN'T SPEND THE MONEY.
ANDREA, YOU KNOW, LIKE EVERYBODY
UP HERE'S TOLD YOU,
VERY, VERY IMPRESSIVE.
THANK YOU.
I'M NOT SURE I BELIEVE
IN THE PRODUCT
AS MUCH AS
I BELIEVE IN YOU.
SO, FOR THAT REASON, I WISH YOU
ALL THE BEST, BUT I'M OUT.
Cuban:
NO, WE'LL DO ALL THE WORK.
WE RUN
ALL THE OPERATIONAL STUFF.
WE'LL DO THE ACCOUNTING.
LOT OF CHATTER OVER THERE.
I'VE GOT PEOPLE
TO DO ALL THE ACCOUNTING.
I MEAN, LOOK, I THINK
YOU'RE A GREAT ROLE MODEL.
THANK YOU.
I THINK, WITH SOME HELP --
YOU KNOW, BARBARA AND I
WORK TOGETHER WELL.
I CAN WHIP UP A WEBSITE
AND GET IT UP AND RUNNING.
Corcoran:
WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
$25,000 FOR 25%.
BUT BETTER THAN THAT,
WE'RE GONNA RUN
ALL THE OPERATIONS FOR YOU.
THE ONLY CONTINGENCY IS
YOU HAVE TO BE AVAILABLE ON-CALL
FOR A SALES CALL.
OKAY.
BECAUSE YOU ARE GONNA
SELL LIKE CRAZY.
YEAH, YOU ARE.
Andrea: THANK YOU.
Corcoran:
SO, $25,000 FOR 25%, LADIES.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
DEAL.
YES!
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OH, MY GOSH.
Greiner: CAN'T BEAT THAT.
WHOO!
THANK YOU.
MY PLEASURE.
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
Andrea: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU SHOULD BE PROUD.
THANK YOU.
Greiner:
NICE JOB. CONGRATULATIONS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
Andrea:
MY LEGS ARE SHAKING SO MUCH.
IT DOESN'T FEEL REAL.
IT FEELS TOO GOOD TO BE TRUE.
AND WE'RE JUST SO EXCITED
TO BE ABLE
TO WORK
WITH MARK AND BARBARA.
BARBARA, I'VE NEVER SEEN YOU
LOOK SO RELAXED.
NO, I'M TELLING YOU, IT TOOK OUT
EVERY BAD MUSCLE IN MY BACK.
JUST LIKE THAT.
MY NAME IS TRINA BARKOURAS.
I'M FROM CORONA DEL MAR,
CALIFORNIA,
AND I'M THE CREATOR
OF HOPPY PAWS.
MY CHILDHOOD WAS DIFFICULT,
TO SAY THE LEAST.
MY PARENTS SPLIT UP
WHEN MY BROTHERS AND I
WERE AT A VERY YOUNG AGE,
AND WE WERE LEFT
TO FEND FOR OURSELVES.
BUT IT WAS A POSITIVE THING.
IT GAVE ME THE TENACITY
AND STRENGTH
TO FIGHT FOR EVERYTHING I HAVE.
BECAUSE MY CHILDHOOD
WAS SO DIFFICULT,
I WANT TO MAKE SURE
I DO EVERYTHING I CAN
TO MAKE MY KIDS FEEL LOVED.
I DECIDED I WANT
MY CHILDREN'S HOLIDAYS
TO BE EXTRA SPECIAL.
SO I CAME UP WITH A GREAT IDEA
THAT GOT THEM REALLY EXCITED.
IT BECAME A FAMILY TRADITION,
AND NOW I'VE DECIDED
TO TURN IT INTO A BUSINESS.
RECENTLY, I GOT SEPARATED,
AND I FOUND MYSELF
ON MY OWN AGAIN.
I LOOK AT CHALLENGES IN LIFE
AS AN OPPORTUNITY.
YOU CAN EITHER WALLOW,
OR YOU CAN GO OUT AND SUCCEED.
GETTING A DEAL
WITH ONE OF THE SHARKS
WOULD MEAN I CAN SHARE
MY FAMILY'S TRADITION
WITH MILLIONS OF FAMILIES
EVERYWHERE.
HI, SHARKS.
I'M TRINA BARKOURAS.
I'M FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA,
AND MY COMPANY IS HOPPY PAWS.
I'M HERE TODAY SEEKING $50,000
FOR A 10% STAKE IN MY COMPANY.
I'VE CREATED
HOPPY PAWS STAMPING KITS
AS A SAFE, SIMPLE,
AND INEXPENSIVE WAY
TO DELIGHT CHILDREN EVERYWHERE
WITH PROOF OF A VISIT
BY SANTA AND HIS REINDEER,
AND MANY, MANY MORE.
SO, SHARKS, LET'S GET YOU
INTO THE HOLIDAY SPIRIT.
'TWAS THE NIGHT
BEFORE CHRISTMAS,
KIDS ARE SNUGGLED IN BED.
TIME TO PREP FOR ST. NICK.
I HAVE NOTHING TO DREAD.
I GRIN TO MYSELF
LIKE A JOLLY OLD ELF
JUST ADD WATER AND STAMP,
BUY THEM RIGHT OFF THE SHELF
IN THE MORNING,
I'LL WAKE TO SQUEALS OF DELIGHT
HOPPY CHRISTMAS TO ALL,
AND TO ALL A GOOD NIGHT.
NOW, WHICH ONE OF YOU SHARKS
WANTS TO SHARE
MY FAMILY TRADITION
AND HOP ALL THE WAY
TO THE BANK WITH ME?
WHAT'S THE PRODUCT?
IT'S AN -- ACTUALLY,
IT'S A STAMPING KIT.
ISN'T THIS WHAT WE USED TO SEE
FOR EASTER FOR --
IS THIS THE SAME BRAND
THAT'S BEEN AROUND FOR YEARS?
NO, BUT I HAVE
SOME SAMPLES FOR YOU.
Greiner:
FOR PAINTING EGGS, YOU MEAN?
LIKE, THOSE -- YEAH.
YEAH.
IT HAS A SIMILAR LOOK TO THE
EGG-PAINTING KIT, DOESN'T IT?
IT HAS A SIMILAR FEEL,
MM-HMM.
HERE YOU GO, ROBERT.
THANK YOU.
HERE YOU GO, LORI.
MR. WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
SO, MY STAMPING KITS
ARE COMPRISED, AS YOU CAN SEE,
OF A BOX,
A THERMOFORM TRAY...
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT.
...POWDER
THAT'S MIXED WITH WATER.
SIMPLY DIP THE STAMP
INTO THE TRAY AND STAMP AWAY.
Corcoran:
WHAT IS IT -- FLOUR?
NO, IT'S ACTUALLY
SUPER-SECRET POWDER.
IT'S A FOOD-GRADE PRODUCT.
DO I JUST WASH IT OFF
WHEN I'M DONE WITH IT?
IT'S ACTUALLY BIODEGRADABLE.
CLEANS UP WITH WATER.
Greiner: SO, YOU COULD DO IT
ON CARPETING?
YOU COULD DO IT ON CARPETING
AND VACUUM IT UP.
AND, SO,
IT'S A SEASONAL PRODUCT.
YOU SELL IT IN ONCE,
AND THEN IT'S DONE.
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I HAVE THE EASTER BUNNY,
SO WE'D MAKE A LITTLE TRAIL
THAT GOES TO THE CHILD'S EASTER
BASKET, AND THEN AN ELF --
I GOT IT.
WHAT'S THE NEXT ONE?
THIS IS THE TOOTH FAIRY.
CHILDREN LOSE 20 TEETH.
NOW, YOU'RE STRETCHING
ON THAT ONE.
WHAT'S YOUR BEST SELLER?
MY BEST SELLER?
UM, WHAT YOU'RE HOLDING
RIGHT THERE IN YOUR HAND,
THAT BOX CAME OFF THE PRESS
YESTERDAY.
SO YOU'RE JUST STARTING
TO SELL ALL THIS NOW?
THIS IS A STARTUP.
OHH!
OHH, OKAY!
SO WE CAN'T REALLY ASK YOU
WHAT'S THE MOST POPULAR,
BECAUSE
YOU'RE JUST FINDING OUT.
CORRECT. 90 DAYS AGO,
I WENT TO SAN DIEGO WITH AN IDEA
AND A VERY ROUGH PROTOTYPE.
WAIT, WAIT. 90 --
THIS ALL STARTED 90 DAYS AGO?
90 DAYS AGO. SO --
SERIOUSLY?
YES.
I CAME UP WITH THIS IDEA
20 YEARS AGO
WHEN MY KIDS WERE LITTLE.
I WOULD GO THROUGH
THIS HOUR-LONG PROCESS
AT NIGHT BEFORE EASTER.
SO, PEOPLE WOULD COME BY
IN THE MORNING,
'CAUSE I'D HAVE THE TRAILS GOING
UP MY WALK, AND THEY'D SAY,
"WHERE DID YOU GET THAT?
I WANT THAT FOR MY KIDS."
WELL, WHAT'S REALLY INTERESTING
IS, THOUGH,
IN THAT FAST OF A TIME,
YOU CREATED YOUR PACKAGING.
YOU CREATED YOUR PRODUCT.
I MEAN, YOU DID A DISPLAY.
I'M A GO-GETTER.
THAT'S A LOT OF WORK.
I'M A SURVIVOR.
YOU DESERVE
A LOT OF CREDIT FOR THAT.
I'VE BEEN ON MY OWN
SINCE I WAS 16 YEARS OLD.
MY MOTHER HAD ME EMANCIPATED.
SHE WALKED INTO A COURT OF LAW
AND SAID,
"I DON'T WANT TO BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THIS LITTLE GIRL
ANY LONGER."
I WENT TO TACO BELL AND MADE
BURRITOS FOR A YEAR AND A HALF
TILL I GRADUATED
FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
I MOVED TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WITH $300, IN MY CAR,
AND HERE I AM TODAY.
I'VE SOLD HOMES
FOR $4 MILLION.
I'M AN INTERIOR DESIGNER.
AND I'M VERY SUCCESSFUL
AT EVERYTHING THAT I DO.
I KNOW THIS IS A GOOD IDEA,
AND I KNOW IT'S A GREAT PRODUCT.
BUT IF YOU'RE SO SUCCESSFUL
AT ALL THOSE THINGS,
HOW DO YOU EVEN
HAVE TIME --
BECAUSE I QUIT ALL OF THAT
TO DO THIS.
YOU QUIT ALL THAT FOR --
THIS IS WHAT I DO FULL-TIME.
WHOA.
Herjavec: NO, YOU DID NOT.
YES, I DID.
I BELIEVE YOU.
I BELIEVE THAT.
WELL, WHAT ARE YOU GONNA
SELL THIS FOR?
OKAY. RIGHT NOW,
ON MY FIRST PRODUCTION RUN,
IT COST ME $2 TO MAKE.
AND THE REASON
I WANT THE $50,000
IS BECAUSE I NEED TO INCREASE
MY PRODUCTION TO 50,000 UNITS
SO I CAN GET IT DOWN
TO UNDER $1.
WHAT ARE YOU
GONNA SELL IT FOR?
Herjavec: OH,
YOU DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GO OUT
AND SPEND ALL YOUR MONEY
ON INVENTORY
BEFORE YOU HAVE SOME ORDERS.
UNLESS YOU'RE WILLING
TO SELL DOOR-TO-DOOR.
OR UNLESS YOU HAVE A PURCHASE
ORDER WE HAVEN'T HEARD ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT? I'M COMPLETELY
FARMING AT MICHAELS RIGHT NOW.
I'M GOING
FOR WALGREENS, WALMART.
WHAT DO THEY TELL YOU?
WHAT DO THEY TELL ME?
I HAVEN'T --
THEY HAVEN'T TOLD ME ANYTHING.
THAT BOX THAT YOU'RE HOLDING
IN YOUR HAND...
YEAH.
...I PICKED THAT UP
AT 5:00 YESTERDAY AFTERNOON.
SO WE DON'T KNOW
IF ANY OF THIS IS GONNA SELL.
HEY, AMEN FOR HUSTLE,
BOY. AMEN.
TRINA, YOU'RE GONNA PAY $2
TO MAKE IT.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA
SELL IT FOR?
$7.99.
O'Leary: TRINA...
...JUST A SERIOUS QUESTION,
BECAUSE I AM MR. WONDERFUL,
AND I CARE
ABOUT BARBARA'S MONEY.
OKAY. [ CHUCKLES ]
WHY DO YOU THINK
IT'S WORTH $500,000?
'CAUSE YOU'RE TELLING ME
I GET 10% FOR $50,000,
ASSUMING A HALF A MILLION DOLLAR
VALUE.
YOU'VE SOLD NOTHING.
I DON'T WANT HER
TO PUT HER MONEY TO WASTE.
SPEAK FOR YOURSELF.
YOU'RE BUYING THIS.
I SWEAR YOU'RE BUYING THIS.
SO, WHY IS WORTH
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS?
LET ME EXPLAIN SOMETHING TO YOU,
MR. WONDERFUL.
I HAVE $105,000
INVESTED IN THIS COMPANY.
IN 90 DAYS?
I KNOW I'M GOING --
IN 90 DAYS.
IN WHAT?
UM, ALL
OF THE GRAPHIC DESIGN,
THE TOOLING FOR THE TRAYS,
THE TOOLING AND THE DIES
TO CUT THE FOAM,
ALL OF THE PRINTING --
Cuban: YOU ARE A MACHINE.
I GIVE YOU CREDIT.
THANK YOU.
I MEAN,
YOU ARE A MACHINE.
THE TRAILER ITSELF --
ALL OF IT.
YOU OWN THE TRAILER, TOO?
YOU OWN THE TRAILER?
YOU BOUGHT THE TRAILER?
THIS IS MY TRADE-SHOW BOOTH.
OH!
WOW!
THIS IS MY TRADE-SHOW BOOTH.
TRINA, TRINA, LOOK.
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO CALL YOURSELF TRINA ANYMORE.
I HAVE RECHRISTENED YOU
"THE BEAST,"
BECAUSE YOU ARE A BEAST.
GRR!
AND I LOVE IT,
AND I WISH MY SALESPEOPLE
WERE ARE FOCUSED AND AS DRIVEN
AND AS EXCITED
ABOUT THEIR VISION.
AND AS CRAZY.
I'M A GO-GETTER.
PEOPLE LOVE THIS PRODUCT.
TRINA, HERE-- HERE'S -- HERE'S
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT YOUR PITCH --
YOU CAN'T IMAGINE
HOW MANY PEOPLE
WE ALL MEET
AROUND THE COUNTRY,
SAY, "I WANT TO
GET ON 'SHARK TANK' ONE DAY."
AND I SAY TO THEM, "WHY DON'T
YOU -- WHY DON'T YOU APPLY?"
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY SAY?
"OH, I'M NOT READY.
I'M GONNA GIVE MYSELF A COUPLE
OF YEARS. I'M GONNA GET READY."
HOW OFTEN
DOES THAT HAPPEN TO YOU?
ALL THE TIME.
AND HERE YOU ARE -- YOU DIDN'T
EVEN HAVE ANYTHING 90 DAYS AGO,
AND -- BANG --
HERE YOU ARE WITH A BUSINESS.
BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S A GOOD IDEA,
AND I KNOW PEOPLE WILL BUY IT.
THAT'S THE GOOD PART.
HERE'S THE BAD PART.
[ CHUCKLES ] NO.
YOU DON'T KNOW
IF PEOPLE ARE GONNA BUY IT.
YOU'RE -- YOU'RE CONFUSING -- I
DON'T MEAN THIS IN A BAD WAY --
A FAMILY TRADITION THAT YOUR
KIDS LIKE WITH A GENERAL MARKET.
MY OPINION IS THAT MY KIDS
WOULDN'T GET SUPER EXCITED
WITH PRINTS ON THE GROUND.
THEY'D SAY, "DADDY,
WHY IS THE CARPET DIRTY?"
UM,
THERE ARE NO SALES TODAY.
CORRECT.
MY OPINION --
I HAVE ONE SALE THREE DAYS AGO.
I WALKED IN COLD.
MY OPINION IS,
KIDS AREN'T GONNA LIKE IT.
THAT'S SIMPLY MY OPINION.
I MIGHT BE WRONG.
FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU, ROBERT.
YOU KNOW, TRINA,
I-I-I ALWAYS SAY
I CAN TELL INSTANTLY
IF IT'S A HERO OR A ZERO.
AND...?
I THINK YOU'RE THE HERO.
THANK YOU.
I MEAN, WHAT YOU'VE DONE
IS AMAZING.
THANK YOU.
MY CONCERN IS, UM, TO MARK'S
POINT ABOUT THE SIMILARITY
TO THE OTHER PRODUCT
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT.
I KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO, LORI.
I WISH YOU COULD SEE
AN EASTER-EGG-DECORATING KIT.
IT MAY RING A BELL FOR YOU, BUT
THIS IS COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
I HAVE MY TRADEMARK PENDING.
I HAVE MY PATENT PENDING.
I'VE DONE MY HOMEWORK
IN 90 DAYS.
I DON'T SLEEP, OKAY?
I'M A CREATIVE MIND ON CRACK.
[ Chuckling ]
I BELIEVE THAT.
THESE TWO PRODUCTS
THAT I HAVE FOR HALLOWEEN,
THEY GLOW IN THE DARK
AT NIGHT.
I THINK THAT'S VERY CLEVER.
MY LITTLE LEPRECHAUN'S
GONNA COME
WITH A LITTLE GREEN VIAL OF DYE
THAT YOU POUR IN THE TOILET
SO YOU KNOW
THAT THE LEPRECHAUN WAS THERE.
KIDS GO CRAZY.
THAT HE PEED IN THE TOILET?
SIX -- YES!
[ LAUGHTER ]
HAVE YOU NEVER HEARD THAT,
BARBARA?
YOU COULD BE --
YOU'VE NEVER HEARD THAT?
I'M IRISH.
I NEVER HEARD OF IT.
YOU KNOW, IT'S REALLY FUNNY,
BECAUSE YOU FASCINATE ME.
I MEAN, I--I'M SITTING HERE
A LITTLE BIT MESMERIZED BY TH--
I DON'T KNOW IF --
I'M SO INTO MY KIDS,
AND I DO EVERYTHING
TO MAKE THEM HAPPY.
AND I'M TELLING YOU,
PEOPLE COME TO ME,
AND THEY SAY,
"WHERE CAN I GET THIS?"
OKAY, TRINA, LET ME HELP YOU.
LET ME HELP YOU.
OKAY.
I AM WILLING TO DO THIS,
BECAUSE I THINK I SHOULD HAVE
A WOMAN WITH HORNS
IN MY PORTFOLIO.
OH, NO!
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
O'Leary:
LET ME HELP YOU.
I AM WILLING TO DO THIS
BECAUSE I THINK I SHOULD HAVE
A WOMAN WITH HORNS
IN MY PORTFOLIO.
I'M GOING TO PUT
THE FIRST $5,000 UP,
OKAY,
AGAINST THE $50,000 ASK.
I WILL PARTNER WITH ANY OTHER
SHARK OR SHARK-ETTE.
I'LL MATCH THAT.
I'LL DO ANOTHER $5,000.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
YOU GOT -- YOU GOT $10,000.
YOU GOT $10,000.
ALL RIGHT! I LIKE IT!
I'M IN! $5,000.
WAIT.
AND IF YOU AND I EACH
GIVE ANOTHER $5,000...
NO, NO, YOU GOT TO
GET TO $50,000.
...SHE'S GONNA BE
HALFWAY THERE.
WE NEED 50% OF THE COMPANY --
50%.
HOW ARE WE
GONNA GET THERE?
NO, I DON'T NEED
50% OF THE COMPANY.
OKAY, 49.9%.
I PUT $105,000 INTO THIS
IN 90 DAYS. LOOK WHERE I AM.
SHE'S ALREADY GOT
$100,000 INTO IT.
I'M UP FOR $5,000.
THAT'S ALL I'M GIVING.
CRAZY IS GOOD, BUT --
TRINA, TRINA, TRINA --
OKAY, ENOUGH.
IS THE AIRSTREAM
PART OF THE BUSINESS?
YES, IT IS.
IT'S IN MY COMPANY.
AND IT'S PAID FOR IN CASH?
EVERYTHING IN MY BUSINESS
IS PAID FOR IN CASH.
I DON'T PAY MYSELF.
I HAVE NO DEBT.
I HAVE NO OTHER INVESTORS.
I OWN 100% OF MY COMPANY.
OKAY, WOULD YOU CONSIDER
THE POSSIBILITY
OF LIMITING YOUR SKUs?
YOU HAVE EIGHT SKUs HERE.
I BELIEVE THERE ARE THREE
THAT ARE GOOD SELLERS...
OKAY.
...EASTER BUNNY,
SANTA'S REINDEER, AND
TOOTH FAIRY TO START OFF WITH.
YES. I WOULD, BARBARA.
OKAY.
BECAUSE IT WOULD CHANGE
THE SIZE OF YOUR DISPLAY,
WHICH WOULD BE
AN ENORMOUS ADVANTAGE
IN SOME OF
THE BIG-BOX STORES.
I HAVE, MY ENTIRE LIFE,
DONE EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE DOING
FOR MY KIDS.
I WOULD TAKE A SPRAY BOTTLE,
OKAY?
I WOULD SPRAY THE FLOOR --
TWO LITTLE DOTS,
THEY DIDN'T LOOK AS GOOD
AS THIS -- AND SPRINKLE IT.
CAN I TELL YOU?
I HAD THE ADVANTAGE
OF WATCHING MY SON RESPOND TO IT
AND NOW
MY 8-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER.
THEY GO CRAZY! THEY FOLLOW THE
TRACKS. THEY CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
IT'S, LIKE, PROOF
THAT SANTA CLAUS EXISTS.
I TOTALLY KNOW
THIS THING WORKS,
AND YOU'VE DONE IT
SO MUCH BETTER.
SO, I WANT
50% OF YOUR BUSINESS...
FOR $100,000.
BA-BAM.
SO, BASICALLY, YOU BOTH PUT IN
THE SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY.
Corcoran:
I'D LIKE TO BE ON EQUAL FOOTING,
AND I'M GONNA TELL YOU WHY.
OKAY.
BECAUSE I'M GONNA WORK
JUST AS HARD AS YOU.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER, IF I DO GET
LARGE PURCHASE ORDERS,
HELPING ME FIND
A LINE OF CREDIT?
OH, NO PROBLEM. I'LL GIVE YOU
THE LINE OF CREDIT.
OKAY.
PURCHASE ORDERS,
I LOVE TO FUND.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER
49% AND 51%?
AS LONG AS YOU CONSIDER
[CHUCKLES]
THAT IF YOU
GET TIRED OF THIS,
THAT YOU THINK
OF YOUR NEXT FIVE IDEAS,
BECAUSE YOU'RE A LITTLE MACHINE
OF IDEAS.
Cuban: SHE'S THE BEAST.
I HAVE TWO MORE.
YOU'RE THE BEAST.
[ Chuckling ] YOU'RE THE BEAST.
AND ALL THOSE IDEAS
ARE OUR IDEAS GOING FORWARD.
OKAY. WE'RE EQUAL PARTNERS
ON THOSE NEW IDEAS.
HOW'S THAT SOUND?
YOU GOT IT. I LOVE IT.
YOU GET 51% NOW. I GET 49%.
I GIVE YOU $100,000,
BUT ON ALL FUTURE IDEAS,
WE'RE 50/50.
OKAY, GREAT.
YEAH.
I'M SO EXCITED. YES!
Cuban: THE BEAST! THE BEAST!
Herjavec: WHOO!
CONGRATULATIONS.
HA HA! THANK YOU.
KEVIN, YOU WERE RIGHT.
THIS WAS A BARBARA DEAL.
I KNEW IT,
AND I'M SO PROUD TO HELP HER.
Greiner: YOU WERE RIGHT
FROM THE BEGINNING.
I KNOW SHE'LL GIVE ME
MY 10% FOR FREE.
BYE, GUYS. THANK YOU.
Cuban: CONGRATS.
Greiner: CONGRATULATIONS.
I HAVE BARBARA ON MY TEAM NOW.
I'M SO EXCITED!
[ CHUCKLES ]
I'M SO EXCITED.
I CAN'T WAIT TO GET STARTED.
TOMORROW'S THE FIRST DAY
OF THE REST OF MY LIFE.
HOW DID YOU KNOW
I WAS GONNA BUY THAT DEAL?
'CAUSE YOU'RE CRAZY.
IT'S A CHRISTMAS MIRACLE!
[ LAUGHTER ]